guys like that kind of know in skin yeah
my [ __ ] looks like a newborn gerbil
laying down my [ __ ] looks like a shaved
rat chilling with his friends on the
[ __ ] in the side brother Wow Wow
damn bro I never realized that thank you
so much god I never realized that my
whole life I've always been looking at
my penis Mike what is this remind me of
potato bro and it is a yam brother
praise God oh yeah thank what you guys
do for Thanksgiving cat I wanted to get
sweet potato pie but after that last
episode all I could think of I couldn't
do it oh I forgot about that just the
cheese cake yeah do my saddle moan it's
crazy cuz since then I've been putting
my dick in a grocery bag at night
shutting the refrigerator it's growing
eyes on the side of it the name hold it
with two other the neighbor kids put
toothpicks in it and put it in a small
cup by the window like what are you
trying to do here God look at Jim
Robbie's just disgusted - hey Jim eight
it's crazy cuz hey how long her chin
comes out with a lawsuit against us oh
the good thing is he he won't have any
footage of us making fun of him yeah
the fire oh yeah or he definitely is
saying the culture corner in court
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]